Dark Fate takes the Terminator franchise back
to basics, resetting the timeline back to
the end of Terminator 2.
Yippee-ki-yay, movie lovers, I'm Jan and in
this video we're diving deep into Terminator:
Dark Fate to analyse the ending, the new timeline
and what it really means for the future of
the franchise.
Plus I'll explain the intriguing way Arnold
Schwarzenegger's Carl connects to the T-800
from Terminator 2, and my predictions on how
the new Skynet, Legion, will be defeated in
possible sequels.
There will, of course, be spoilers for Dark
Fate and other movies in the franchise.
Although it's the sixth Terminator movie,
Dark Fate is a direct sequel to Terminator
2.
The events of T2 mean that Skynet no longer
exists in the new film.
However, the unstoppable march of artificial
intelligence means a new AI system called
Legion goes bad instead.
Legion then sends a Rev-9 terminator back
in time from the future to assassinate Dani,
the future leader of the resistance in this
new timeline.
The Rev-9 racks up a brutal body count and
is relentless in its pursuit because it can
recover from virtually any physical damage
including being sent through a turbine in
the final showdown.
As a final resort, augmented human Grace tells
Dani she must use her power source to fry
the machine's neural net processor.
Removing the power source from Grace kills
her, but Dani is able to jam it into the Rev-9's
skull, short circuiting many of its functions.
To finish the killer cyborg off, an injured
Carl reactivates and holds the killer cyborg
down while the power source burns them up
shutting both of them down, effectively killing
them.
This ending combines the finale of Terminator
2 when the T-800 came back to life after its
secondary power source activated to rescue
John Connor from the T-1000 and the ending
of Terminator 3: Rise of the Machines where,
like Dani, the T-850 jammed its own power
source into the skull of the T-X terminator,
killing them both:
"You are terminated."
With the Rev-9 defeated, the future resistance
leader Dani has been saved.
But a future apocalypse where the A.I. system
Legion turns against its human creators still
hasn't been avoided, so it's similar to the
first Terminator movie where John Connor's
future is saved but the apocalypse isn't prevented.
In the very final scene of Dark Fate, Dani
watches a young Grace who's still alive in
the present day and she vows to Sarah that
she won't let Grace die for her again.
In other words Dani wants to break the time
loop that in the future forces her to send
adult Grace back in time to die for her.
This final playground scene is also a cool
homage to the iconic scene from Judgment Day
where Sarah had an apocalyptic vision of the
future and foresaw the nuclear catastrophe
that Skynet would inflict on the world.
Dark Fate links that moment from T2 which
was what drove Sarah to prevent the rise of
Skynet with Dani's own decision to change
the future and stop the rise of Legion.
So Dark Fate leaves the future open to change
making this new sequel to Terminator 2 a lot
more hopeful and optimistic than Terminator
3: Rise of the Machines, the original sequel
which took a fatalistic view that despite
everything Sarah Connor did to stop Judgment
Day in T2, Armageddon at the hands of Skynet
was unavoidable.
"We stopped Judgment Day."
"You only postponed it.
Judgment Day is inevitable."
That third film killed off Sarah Connor and
finished with the nuclear apocalypse that
had been averted in T2.
"Our destiny was never to stop Judgment Day.
It was merely to survive it..."
Dark Fate, by contrast, actually reveals that
there's a glimmer of hope and the future of
artificial intelligence may not be as catastrophic
as seen in previous sequels after T2.
Dark Fate's Carl is the perfect example of
how a destructive A.I. machine can actually
become a friend to humans and actively work
to do good.
Carl was a T-800 that was sent back by Skynet
together with other terminators to make sure
that one of them completed the mission to
assassinate John Connor.
Before Carl got to John, the events of Terminator
2 destroyed Cyberdyne and the existence of
Skynet was erased from the future.
Despite this, as a machine, Carl had to follow
the mission he'd been programmed to perform.
But after he kills John, he has no further
instructions from Skynet, so he follows his
other programmed directive which is to blend
in with human society so he can carry out
any missions covertly.
And with over 20 years of continuous machine
learning about human society under his belt,
Carl has transformed into something almost
human.
In fact, Carl's evolution can be seen as what
would have happened to the T-800 from Terminator
2 if it hadn't sacrificed itself at the end
of that movie.
In T2, Uncle Bob, as John Connor nicknamed
him, learned over the course of just a few
days how to become more human, even picking
up slang:
"No problemo."
"Hasta la vista, baby."
Another interesting parallel between Carl
and Bob is how they both became benevolent
father figures.
Carl helped rescue a woman and her child from
an abusive husband and, when he talks about
how reliable he is, it echoes what Sarah thought
of the T-800 from Terminator 2.
"Watching John with the machine, it was suddenly
so clear.
The Terminator would never stop.
It would always be there.
Of all the would-be fathers who came and went,
this thing, this machine, was the only one
who measured up."
And as a measure of how human Carl has become,
notice how in Dark Fate we see the machine
sitting comfortably next to the family's dog.
This is in stark contrast to what was established
in the first Terminator movie, that dogs instinctively
bark and get nervous when a terminator is
nearby as they have an ability to detect Infiltrator
units.
"I was dreaming about dogs."
"We use 'em to spot Terminators."
Carl even seems to have acquired a form of
his own free will.
When he meets Sarah, he tells her that because
she chose to change the future, Skynet now
no longer exists, meaning that he's been set
free because he has no further orders to follow.
And now he's choosing to make his own autonomous
decision to protect Dani.
"I'm going to help you protect the girl because
I choose to."
Carl's freedom and ability to make his own
decisions also fits well the phrase "no fate
but what we make" that first appeared in T2:
"The future is not set.
There is no fate but what we make for ourselves."
This is echoed again in Dark Fate's flash-forward
scenes from the future where Dani rescues
Grace from attackers who are after her food.
Dani tells the other humans that they shouldn't
be fighting amongst themselves but joining
together to fight the machines instead.
When one of them says there's no point as
they can't win, Dani urges them to resist
fate, a belief that rallies people to her
cause and builds an army that is fighting
to take the world back from the machines.
So, given the terrifying future we see in
Dark Fate's flash-forward scenes, what chance
do Dani and Sarah have of defeating Legion
in future sequels?
Well, the movie sets up several interesting
possibilities.
The first thing to consider is that in Dark
Fate the catastrophe happens over several
days, when Legion, an A.I. designed for cyber
warfare, becomes self-aware and begins its
attack on humanity by turning off the power
grid.
The next day, humans attempt an EMP attack
on Legion that fails, which leads to a full
world war by the third day.
That was eventually followed by famine which
wiped out the majority of humanity, with Legion
then hunting down any remaining human survivors.
As terrible as that scenario is, it's a slower
wipe-out than nuclear annihilation, and it
allows for a window of time where Dani and
Sarah could attempt to prevent the catastrophe
from playing out in its entirety.
Something I've already mentioned on is how
Carl is a great example of how a machine can
learn and become something almost human with
the ability to make its own decisions rather
than follow a hard-coded set of rules.
This is something that Sarah and Dani both
witnessed and might investigate further.
For example, they could find a way to change
how Legion's machines operate so they live
together with humans rather than kill them.
In fact, there's a deleted scene from Terminator
2 that's in the Extended Cut where the T-800
explains to John that his machine learning
mode is something that has to be switched
on.
"Can you learn stuff you haven't been programmed
with?
So you can be...
you know, more human?"
"My CPU is a neural-net processor, a learning
computer.
But Skynet presets the switch to 'read only'
when we are sent out alone."
"Doesn't want you to do too much thinking,
huh?"
"No."
"Can we reset the switch?"
Someone who might come in useful for this
is Sarah Connor's contact Major Dean, the
military officer who has an alliance with
Sarah.
Major Dean was only in Dark Fate briefly,
handing over the EMP device to Sarah.
But in an interview with IGN, director Tim
Miller explained that "Dean was originally
in more scenes and that he's a military intelligence
officer who is wary of AI and had turned to
Sarah Connor to help him out on a few missions."
By the way, if you're at all confused by the
circular nature of time travel in the Terminator
franchises and the time paradoxes it creates,
well, it's basically different to the recent
very popular time travel movie Avengers: Endgame
in which time travel creates new [branching]
timelines and alternate realities.
In Dark Fate and the Terminator franchise,
time travel is a closed loop in which changing
the past rewrites the future.
"That's not how it works."
"Well, that's what I heard."
"Wait, but who?
Who told you that?"
"Star Trek, Terminator.."
"Time doesn't work that way.
Changing the past doesn't change the future."
Even if logically this seems to be impossible,
Dark Fate director Tim Miller has said he
prefers this type of time travel, despite
the plot holes and paradoxes it creates, because
it means higher stakes for the characters.
Even though Carl was damaged beyond any likely
repair in Dark Fate, it's still possible for
Schwarzenegger to return in a sequel as a
brand new character, perhaps even a human
next time around.
James Cameron has said it's unlikely Legion
would attempt to "build an Arnold T-800 in
the Legion version of the future because that's
a different technological developmental pathway."
However, there could still be more Arnold
T-800s kicking around that Skynet sent back,
but what could be more interesting is if we
met the human being that Skynet based its
T-800 designs on.
In a Q&A in 2007, Cameron said:
"It has flashed through my mind that there
has to have been a prototype.
There has to have been a guy...
that they grew the Terminator from...
and that presumably was a real person at some
point.
And did that person have some sort of meaning
to Skynet on why they chose that one?"
Now, what do you think of Terminator: Dark
Fate?
And do you have any theories or things you'd
like to see in potential sequels?
Leave your thoughts in the comments below
and if you enjoyed this, then embrace your
inner movie lover by hitting that subscribe
button to get all my future videos.
Tap left for more breakdowns of your favourite
movies or tap right for another video you're
sure to like.
Thanks for watching and see ya next time.
Yippee-ki-yay, movie lovers!